when they chart the decline of this
Empire yeah the soft pencil you're nuts
dude is getting mentioned oh my God you
bring me here and do this to me soft
prenzel is there's nowhere to go from
there that's that's going to be positive
no what so Philly Soft Pretzel is a
company Philly Soft Pretzel Company I'm
well aware sure for the listeners in the
midwest he owns
30% he's got three
locations I just open went out of
Hampton
content purposes alone the three of us
should open a soft a Philly Soft Pretzel
Company no it' be amazing and it would
be getas in the H it would be the shout
out to Ras by the way I love Ras but it
would be the best episode of Undercover
Boss cuz immediately they all be like oh
these [__] three of us we all
have fake mustaches on and [__] we're
like what's folio like what's a
prin we don't know